like a slit of a perfection what is it
okay let's talk about do you really
notice the differences of that and I
guess I'm shallow in that way a very
shallow what are you not like what's it
what's an undesirable vision was first
of all it has to look like a vagina
sometimes it looks like like an ID went
off on it that's what mine looks like
right now it does to babies and to
episiotomy what does this position they
make a little cut so then the baby comes
out of the car have you have you looked
at your vagina in the mirror yeah it's
horrible like what is it just described
to be verbally just imagine scientific
or scientific science alert well okay so
they cut it and so it's like it makes
like a big HOV Lane right so like it's
it was stitched up so like it's healed
but the bottom part is a little more
crooked do you not I mean it was
stitched twice I've had that oh my god
right the rest is looks like it did like
it always did yeah right yeah but that's
the actual like what he's referring to
your so your vagina is fine it's just
crooked good
yeah the meat the meat if I saw it in a
photo it has but I didn't know was yours
yeah let's play this game yeah and I
look at it now you have like five photos
I go which one I pick it and usually
like no that's a baby Bobby the baby's
vagina oh [ __ ] that's what I assumed
what I just said no because I could say
I liked it I want I want to be able to
do the podcast and say whatever I want
you know why cuz if I said whatever I
wanted yeah you can air it you've
watched your mom's house no I mean I
want to see
illegal things yeah
what Santino and I did one as an
experiment six months ago you could just
come over we're gonna do one that we're
not gonna air and I just want to see
what that is yeah and my god
it's the best one we've ever it's the
funniest one I've ever done uh narrable
is it about what Hitler baby FS uh I
mean yeah we did we boosted a lot every
word every word that's true but how
freeing would that be but let's do a
super super podcaster so it's like Ethan
and Gila yeah yeah Rogen or Ebert Tom
and like a mega inappropriate roundtable
roundtable Wow Bert would take over you
think there would dominate we know we
get him so drunk he'll get to a point
you get him drunk enough he'll just go
inside himself that's what we want shut
him down and shut down that personality
what we have burnt here are you just
trying to remember
like I'm in a but you guys think about
his own liquor yeah
that's cuz we didn't we didn't even have
ice for him cuz you do have ice in your
house yeah we don't even have households
have ice in the freezer okay so we don't
I don't think it was weird until birth
came over and he's like you guys don't
have any [ __ ] I never thought about
it and then I realized that ice is a
treat for me like when I'm on a plane I
asked for the crushed ice and it may I
sit there and so much joy just yeah
rolling around my high five ourselves of
ice so that's helpful yourself yeah
sweet when I go over to my sister's
house the first thing I do is I get the
crushed ice machine but a little
pineapple juice and they sit there guys
I get enjoy he's gonna make her like a I
sand maker in your fridge maybe seen her
fridge it's from the 70s so that's why
you that's why what about a tray I know
what to get you for Christmas an ice
cube tray are you high when I bought
this hunk condo
years ago there was it was a brand new
no one ever lived here and then the guy
was like the realtor guy was like you
gotta get a fridge and I've never bought
a fridge before I went to wherever the
fridges are sold fridge are us I don't
know
I believe oh yeah I walked in there and
this was the cheapest one because in my
head I'm like I'm not ever gonna have a
girlfriend have anyone live here yeah so
I'll skip that I don't cook at home yeah
so I just bought that piece of [ __ ] and
it's now I regret it but we're gonna
find a new place you're hot I'm going to
your house and inspired us to really we
even looked in your area really I would
love to have you as neighbors don't be
so fun would we do you really believe
that we would see each other yeah if you
live close it's all about proximity the
older yet especially we have children
yeah I just see whoever's closest if
you're gonna come by yeah I'm not
leaving my house yeah yeah yeah if we
were like two blocks away you would walk
over no no why would we have to tiny
baby I go no so if I knocked on the door
I go it's me Bob come on I could come in
of course Wow worse would you just do
like a lurker on her hedges no I just
sit there and get whatever they
lollipops or whatever babies do yeah
[Applause]
what do babies do frolic frolic frolic
and I was just you know prance around
with the yeah yeah yeah and then go
alright see you
[Music]